the pennzoil 400 is sunday in the las
vegas motor speedway who is sponsoring
this next segment lets you feel like a
real driver with their nascar experience
jc visited the track for test run
as we get ready for race day we're
taking you inside the nascar racing
experience but before we hit the track
we gotta hit the classroom
todd my man
what's going on buddy good to see you
again i'm ready to hit the track today
i'm excited about this but tell me more
about the experience people walk in to
check in what do we do here yeah so this
is our media center here what we're
going to do is we're going to come in
and sign our track waiver uh we're gonna
give you a lanyard it's got an sd card
in it for a video if you want to
purchase it uh then once you uh are
checked in here you're gonna walk over
here and basically i'm gonna put you in
a fire suit um and then from there we're
gonna go right into the classroom this
is where the teaching is this is it
where it happens this is it right here
so this is our our uh instructor
classroom in here you're going to go
through a 25 minute uh video uh and then
from here you're going to go out to the
racetrack where you're going to have a
second part of the classroom we call it
our pit road speech uh once we have the
pit road speech then we get you in the
race car now there's two options too you
can drive the car itself well that's
what we're doing today i'm doing the
ride-along i want you the master of the
track to take me around sure no worries
let's go you're ready for a
but where do you guys keep the cars
holy smokes this is incredible
isn't this amazing in here yeah what do
we got here these are actual race cars
that we get from the teams back uh on
the east coast all right um we put our
own engine in it we put a couple of
seats and a dash and we basically call
it a day we don't do much to these cars
these cars are actually
that's right that's right but this is
the one
that you really should be interested in
this is the one that we're going to
drive into this one joey logano joy
legano
yeah yeah with the pennzoil 400 coming i
think this should be the car
[Music]
go ahead and put your left leg over all
right then you're right
go ahead and slide down into the foot
compartment there
help you with your helmet
there you go good job i do have a
question this is the steering wheel you
just attached it have you ever been
driving the thing popped out never okay
because what i do is i do uh
i test the steering wheel and pull on it
just to make sure and that's standard
nascar steering this is standard yep
you'll always see the guys it's a quick
release it's called okay so basically
what you're going to do is is reach
through the steering wheel pull back on
it and then put it on the steering
column and then you're always going to
test it and pull it back perfect here we
go let's do it time
so
[Music]
[Music]
wow that's how it's done that's how you
go 165 miles an hour we did 165 165
right there buddy
that is the nascar experience thank you
guys hey thank you jc great to have you
out here man i'm ready for the race
let's do it let's go
head over to
eightnewsnow.com contest for your chance
to win a family four pack to the
pennzoil 400 at the las vegas motor
speedway las vegas now we'll be right
back